and for today's Bart chart is cheap oil
causing a burger bubble yes a burger
bubble we're a US consumers spending all
the cash they're saving on cheap
gasoline that's a question essentially i
want to ask today now the answer could
lie in this chart this is the standard &
poor's super composite restaurants index
it's an index of 23 companies you might
be familiar with one or two of them were
talking McDonald's here we're talking
yum brands which owns KFC and Starbucks
to name but a few now this index is
essentially the home of burgers of wings
of pizzas of cheesecakes and of
frappuccinos and right now it's trading
at an all-time high going way back to
january nineteen ninety-five
year-to-date it's up by four percent
from its low in october last year it
jumped seventeen percent the
best-performing shares on thursday the
twelfth of februari were wendy's up 23%
year-to-date sonic up seventeen percent
year today Papa John's up thirteen
percent from 1985 the far left of your
screen it's risen more than eight times
its initial value of 100 by the way the
S&P 500 is risen in here four and a half
times over the same period but a very
good question to ask is this how cheaper
these stocks well the index is trading
at twenty five point six times reported
earnings about twenty five percent above
its average over the last decade on a
forward-looking basis the stocks aren't
looking cheeping that the index is
trading at twenty-three point six times
what analysts predict the companies will
learn over the next 12 months that's an
all-time high and more than a quarter
above its decade average very quickly if
you needed more evidence of the appetite
for these types of company for those
burger companies look no further than
Shake Shack the burger chain it's sold
shares for the first time on January the
29 a $21 shares more than doubled on
their first day of trading they're
resting at forty dollars sixty-five
burger anyone